[Music]
[Music]
fire
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
we're talking about fashion guys how
about chin again today dude single now
you're dressing like a detective he's
got the [ __ ] Chelsea boots on but the
real thin Soul it's raining those are
the thinnest Souls I've ever seen those
are borderline Chelsea moccasins right
there Bob that that is a that that soul
is about as thin as a potato chip it has
to hurt and that's when you know you're
getting those or sandals that Brian
wears yeah well Chelsea's can get comfy
though oh you got you got actual shoes
on today
um it was just raining and I decided
[ __ ] it I'm gonna wear my shoes I'm
gonna wear some sneakers you feel caged
in do you feel claustrophobic no no no
sometimes Nails sometimes I feel a
little insecure that I might have to get
into a little tuss up and I want some
traction under my feet if I'm gonna get
in some truck now because now my wet out
don't get me wrong my toes have vibrant
Souls now Vibram Souls but they'll be
just attraction Zone I want some
traction I want well I might have to
just I want my toes covered sometimes
when I'm gonna start throwing my feet
you know what I mean yeah because if I
fight Brennan I throw my feet you won't
be covered yeah on my feet that's all
daddy wants to be covered I'm not mad at
the rain though no I don't know every
older person we need it my dad we need
it we need it oh yeah we need do we we
need it do we well you know I was in
England and it had been dry for 55 days
and they were like freaking out and then
when I was leaving England the rain was
so heavy we were going 20 miles an hour
and the [ __ ] guy in the car was like
we need it we need about literally dead
serious he goes we need a good uh a good
a good two months of this uh you know I
don't know I was like what he goes all
right our aquifiers are all all dry so
I'm like you guys think you have
problems you don't know dry [ __ ]
I go we've been we've had I go we've had
a drought for three years and he goes oh
I know I know I know you have and I was
like God you keep up with the water
table in California I do it's their
thing it's California it's their [ __ ]
through the almonds though you know did
I tell you what that I was uh that the
guys who they're not the healthiest in
the English Countryside if you work on a
farm you usually are sitting on a
tractor you're smoking a lot of tobacco
you're drinking a lot and you're not
missing anything fish all right deep
fried man I I loved myself though yeah
but you can hear them breathing and they
gotta hoof it across up here
it's like
yeah it's just the cigs yeah well my so
the guy was driving me was 70. and I
said yeah and he was in shape he looked
good and I said you know you look like
you're good he goes I do I like my rum
though I like my rum I'll drink I'll
drink uh I'll dress how much run do you
drink honestly I drink I drink a whole
bottle if I can't even two but it's over
a period of time and I said that's good
and he goes I said but you know you must
be granted you have your grandchildren
you're kind of heels yeah I'll just do
this you know I said but you're kind of
[ __ ] because I am I am working in
construction a long time but All My
Friends Are Dead you know so that's the
problem you're 70. he goes yeah none of
them made it I'm the last one standing I
was like well that's a problem you're
70. right the boosting so it's really
the worst things it should stay the
poison so my buddy went he's he's never
missed a [ __ ] drink and he eats like
four men he smokes cigarettes he smokes
weed and he drinks all the wine
cigarettes a doctor looked at his mouth
and he had these white spots oh and he
was like he goes now that's what's
called pre-cancerous and he goes I gotta
stop smoking he goes no you got to stop
drinking drinking is actually the larger
culprit
and then he uh
and then he said then he said he looked
at the doctor and he goes like this he
goes well what do you think I should do
and the doctor stopped and went
practice some self-restraint for God's
sake that's what he said My Buddy
started laughing good doctor I I was
with my buddy who is the most macho guy
I've ever met every bit as big as you
are
and he had an operation he's made a lot
of money okay he's he he he had an
operation he had to have an operation
okay
and the one thing you do before you go
under anesthesia is you do not eat
you're supposed to fast yeah you can't
because you'll die if you throw up and
you have a reaction when I tell you he
ate the kind of meal that a king would
eat you know when they Feast yeah you
eat like Duck Partridge bring out the
Pheasant now we have the deer this is
death yeah it was a death Romeo yeah and
I go you you're under the knife in
literally I'm counting it seven hours
Rosie okay he doesn't give a [ __ ] I know
but he was okay right 100 I know 100 do
you man you might be that way I feel
like no I would listen to that you're as
close as it gets though to somebody who
doesn't really give a [ __ ] you'll roll
the dice I'll roll the dice Daddy's
starving but here it says uh which is
worse alcohol or smoking although the
danger of drinking smoking are very
different according to annual death
numbers smoking is worse than drinking
the United States estimated 88 000
people die from alcohol causes issues
but about Jesus Christ's not even close
480 000 people die from tobacco okay you
don't see a lot of people smoking
anymore no
well you know now I was gonna have for
the party you're missing I was gonna
have uh we're gonna have a green bar
what's the green bug well A friend of
mine has a connection with some of the
best weed on the planet so we were going
to have a green bar we're gonna have
grab bags and weed some of my family
members the older ones oh they said no I
wouldn't we're not coming no I wouldn't
either and I went well no I would come
but it would be weird oh they were like
no because we have kids there yeah but
also it's legal but I don't behave but
they were like you 22 well are you a
tick tocker well but also it was more
like I don't want to bring my kids
around that which I respected and I went
well if it's between a green bar and my
family members [ __ ] the green bar you
put on something like your dad and your
mama I got it what is this I get it oh
you can just go smoke weed listen I know
it's 20 22 but I got it it is legal I
have a little respect I know but it is
hey Dad you mind if I put you on this
Tick Tock put a filter on your face but
it is legal right yeah and and Whiskey's
technically most prostitution substates
you want hookers at your wedding
I mean now that I'm a board okay I'm
just saying if there's a hooker bar
I mean well hooker Buffet if there's a
hook or Buffet that's what you would
call it like in New Amsterdam if you I
mean in Amsterdam do you know District
yeah now they've got women in
essentially in a in a booth you know in
a see-through Booth yeah well the only
problem with that is sex trafficking
like it's it gets down no no they they
get no they have health there's still
traffic no they have health care well
yeah they're citizens yeah they pay
taxes yeah in Amsterdam they pay taxes
and they pay their pimps out there no no
amp stamps a little bit different oh
geez oh my God no there's this there's
still you know okay that's insane and
she's just on her cell phone she's just
there there's the mark Harley of
prostitutes she's just at work but still
on herself she just [ __ ] booth and
men can just walk by and you'll [ __ ]
whoever and you just knock on the glass
yeah and then tell them to come in
that's right look at that
but then hold on when you pick one does
it is it like close for business yeah
and you just go into the red house
but I'm who's been Amsterdam and him
I've not nobody you win mark to that
place well like you walk by it yeah
how's it work
um
I didn't buy any prostitutes but there
are there are in the windows but you
just walk by and they're like yeah
negotiate like you can you can approach
them and negotiate I don't think there's
a picture wait look at that one
there has to be some like Madam right my
friend went in and he was like you know
she said some Eastern European chicks
like I said go to dig for 20 euros
[Laughter]
man I'm kind of a fan that's fake oh
expecting where's that at look at this
it's kind of real and that might be and
you of course there's God I hope it is
2020.
like hey hey chin bring me to the girls
man
oh God Walk around an area that's like
we you know glamorize it but it's like
the red light District's not a good area
of Amsterdam oh is it is it yeah
considered you know a more dangerous
place uh well anytime you're gonna have
like any when you think about like those
those places in uh New York they have
where it's like the circle you can do
math and it's okay it can't be in a good
area there you go
I know but tomorrow actually it's still
dicey yeah is it
well it's been there it's regulated yeah
I mean just it's still more reputation
wise like my you know I had a friend who
said like you got followed around there
it just you know you think of it and
then maybe you're on edge can I see that
made the maid right there this is the
French media
now I'm just saying
that is interesting be cool to
experience it sometime but you mean just
to walk by or to experience it but it's
like if you go down uh you know was it
Figaro of Street and downtown where the
hookers aren't on Worldstar they'll show
them like Jesus Christ like they're like
tense but you go down there it's it's a
dice
you mean down right right by downtown
really seriously super dicey yeah yeah
I'm not going into some hotel with
somebody
yeah I mean that's me right there all
right there I am there are those poor
girls though too like it's like ah you
know it's the guys that walked out are
like holy but it's his oldest time and
oh yeah some girls but prostitution is
legal in some States of uh I think just
Nevada no I thought they opened up
elsewhere too
oh no uh New York
I thought New York just passed that I
think I think it should all be a legal I
mean oh me too if you want to pay to
have sex
and you you want to enter into it it is
anyway
yeah you're right now that's the only
one Boston is legal in all but seven 17
counties counties
yeah yeah because it's not legal in the
Vegas but that's why that Bunny Ranch
was right outside there
so interesting
yeah
well I bet again with human trafficking
which is the big
thing with the cartel and the healthy I
don't know about that that brings as
much problem in the United States but
it's certainly oh man oh bro you're so
wrong massive problem yeah massively we
like with uh Mass immigrants oh dude
coming in the massive massive brother
yeah number one problem yeah yeah huge
human trafficking insane yeah huge huge
yeah wow yeah huge problem bring that up
chin human trafficking the United States
yeah I was watching this thing out it's
a real problem real problem yeah because
it's it's hard to tell human trafficking
that it's drugs now so obviously the
cartels are the dark the dark arts
yeah
um occurs in the United States include
Transportation yep
it has been necessary that two-thirds of
trafficking victim in the United States
are U.S citizens do you know where else
they use them in in the weed Farms
apparently that's made between 15 000
and 50 000 women and girls of traffic
each year in the United States but a lot
of those a lot of people that are used
um so if they're not you sex they're
used in sort of essential indentured
servitude and no in in picking the uh
the weed processing the weed spraying
the weed that was that's basically
they're giving them jobs there but
you're saying they don't pay them though
no no or they make very little money
because they're illegal that's terrible
and so now they have them in these these
sort of like Barracks terrible yeah
yeah not good yeah not good yeah I guess
the hardest to detect is a human you
know it's hard to tell
nightmare it is they caught that one I I
don't know he was a he was a heavyweight
boxer They seized the most was it
fentanyl cocaine ever cocaine ever ever
are you the former heavyweight champ
they come in Miami
but they season look at this Falcons
charged with uh
it's estimated a street value of a I
don't know estimated value one point but
one over a billion but then street value
is like half that or something like that
wow
and he's from uh Serbia or something or
there it is 20 metric tons of cocaine
whoa that's going to carry a couple
sentences that's going to be a little
bit of a problem she's denying it though
he had a street value over one thing
organized crime of course
don't [ __ ] with those guys Jesus
uh so his name is
an expert on porch shipping willing to
work deals with many different groups
Jesus Christ Europe is said to have
surpassed the United States a single
large cocaine Market it's because we
have inflation here right
I mean you know uh the Europeans
Belgian Serbia and Albania
and the Italian you got some you're
dealing with that's like that that show
triple zero which is about the great
show yeah but I told you our buddy who
deals in the dark arts was like America
has no money man so they're taking
everything they ship it everywhere else
but America like America's flooded with
drugs but people aren't they're not
inflation like they got all the [ __ ] to
deal with wow yeah he's like so now it's
all Europe Australia like it's all going
that direction Jesus he's actually
because the market here's flooded so
prices are down and collection affects
everything got that interesting yeah
yeah it's a whole thing yeah it's a
whole thing man cocaine is something
people will always do
that is I've never done it yeah there's
nothing good about cocaine nothing it's
not like you've no one has ever done
cocaine and said the next day I'm glad I
did that no one because it really messes
you up right it's not that it's just a
I'm saying like the next day dungeon
yeah and it's like it's a Non-Stop thing
so if you do it to keep that high it
goes away really chasing the dragon you
keep doing it and your body just you
feel like it's like the joke is I think
Mike young has a joke where it's like
you just you end up starting a business
you know it's like let's start a
business yeah
you just have this euphoric feeling
where you're just like this is the
greatest day oh why did I why did I buy
three pawn shops last year yeah exactly
whose idea was this and you're really
horny too when I knew it was bad oh but
your wiener doesn't work yeah so it's
the worst possible thing on the opposite
some people it does most people I heard
that's a common most people it doesn't
work I'm the opposite well who has that
joke like you know uh God's messing with
this kid yeah it's so great who says
that but someone does I forget no I
would be the opposite of that but when I
realized cocaine was bad as I was a
young man I was in Jamaica
and I was smoking weed and some guy gave
me blow he was an american guy who was
staying at the resort and I had nothing
to do good time so I was like I'll try
this and I ended up writing
a stand-up all night kind of kept waking
my girlfriend up telling her how funny
it was yeah
you know what my genius idea was what if
God was a Rastafarian
hilarious tropical hilarious
oh and I was right here well now I'm on
board it was the worst thing you don't
want me as a partner I'm always very
positive glass half full the worst
couple we should film this don't put it
out right now I wanted it right there I
was like unedited I'm like yeah I'm a
genius it was the worst [ __ ] I've ever
written in my I took it all and I balled
it up and threw away and I was like oh
that's an evil drug now imagine if you
had money and you [ __ ] bought like
seven pawn shops or at Toys R Us I'm
gonna buy the last Toys R Us in the
California I have a feeling being manic
or bipolar like Kanye is what happens
you either have this like like you're
I'm gonna fix the world and I'm gonna
blame the Jews or you know or whatever
it is kind of things a little more
deeper I mean well mental
Mania yeah being the guy that uh
diagnosed him on that's a little weird
but it's like you want to call him a
genius and they just manic but it's also
the way his brain works you know clearly
he's a genius when it comes to Art and
stuff like that but also as a
businessman he's genius you know he's
the richest African-American of all time
right here the rich black man America
now that what this has gone I think
someone else jumped ahead of him but
still but Kanye has always done
polarizing things before to get a
reaction he doesn't care he just wants
reaction he's done with white people
who's done with black beer we do with
black people you know people weren't
upset when he said slavery was a choice
but he was doing all this to get a rise
right he had an album coming out we've
talked about this
I really think that uh I don't think
he's crazy I don't think he you know
he's manic what I do think you don't I
don't I think what's going on is this
was all planned because he wanted out of
his contract he had a six year deal with
Adidas and I any idea with Balenciaga
deal with gap and he felt like they were
taking advantage of him if you look at
what Gap did and I'm not defending Kanye
but if you take out the anti-semitic
stuff which I do not tolerate at all but
if you look at what Gap was doing to him
and
um Adidas in the contract they had all
these deals then they started to make
knockoffs of his stuff he's like whoa
what the [ __ ] identical [ __ ] just not
gone Yeezy he's like what are you doing
dude wow those are my designs like I
know but we need to make a profit so
we're going to make them for less and
sell them he's like well now you're
cutting into my profit like you got a
six year contract what are you gonna do
he's like excuse me like we own you I
didn't know that so do you think there's
a message this madness he's always done
this so he was like okay cool I'm gonna
get out of this like good luck is it
cool so he goes on drinking and Champs
and he of course Kanye is too smart
smart businessman to realize the
repercussions I think he underestimated
the repercussions of going anti-semitic
I think he poked the wrong Bull and we
mess with the Jews and with their
history bro you're asking for a lot of
grief back I think he underestimated the
blowback he wanted to get out of those
deals he even went on drinking Champs
goes I can say anti-semitic [ __ ] and
Adidas won't do anything Knowing damn
well they're going to do something
because Adidas a german-owned company
right yes they definitely can't tolerate
that so he knew that was the one route
he can take that will guarantee him to
get out of the contract the only problem
is anti-Semitic nobody [ __ ] that stuff
nobody dude so he didn't realize the
blowback now he did get out of the
contract knows he's out of all the
contracts Gap Balenciaga Adidas he's out
of the contracts
so now you can go to get his home now
you can manufacture you can do an
apology tour well he's already
apologizing but do you say in the media
have you seen his apology did anybody in
here know you apologize you apologize
well no days ago but then he said also
he was diagnosed by a doctor and the
doctor was a Jewish doctor
that's not an apology well no that was
he actually apologized for the
anti-semitic stuff but that's not the
news right
the false claims about George Floyd now
let me ask you this did you know that
Candace Owens was uh supporting the
George family did you know uh Kanye West
was supporting the George Floyd family
for all this time anybody know that you
see on the headlines you know he was
giving them money do you guys know any
of this no nothing
nothing there's nothing on that kind of
oh he's crazy he's going through a manic
thing blah blah blah but his goal is to
get out of these contracts so he can own
it all himself even though he's a
billionaire I think his biggest issue is
there's there's death this is not about
the Jews yeah because he said George
Floyd was killed by fentanyl not the cop
which he's wrong now did George Floyd
have fentanyl on his body 100 did George
Floyd did the fentanyl help him
absolutely not but would he have died if
that cop didn't put the knee on his neck
probably not you know what I'm saying
but then the fentanyl definitely didn't
help so he's going with that narrow
which is the wrong you know it's tough
to do but there's definitely Fentanyl
and George George Floyd's body that's
facts those are just facts right so he
that was he was awfully apologized for
that right
but his goal ultimately was to take all
ownership of his brand which is
literally as far as an individual goes
the biggest brand in the world and get
all his own manufacturing he can do that
now and you're out of your mind if you
don't think he's gonna make more money
now doing his own manufacturing even
with this stuff
my only thing is if I was on his team
and clearly he's surrounded by yes man
so because if he would have said hey all
right this time I'm going to do
anti-semitics like bro you're really
barking up the wrong tree
but he's going to make more money but
it's also how much money do you need to
look at what's done to your
this you went too far this time too far
but now he owns everything he owns it
all you like Adidas lets them go Adidas
don't own the easy brand the yay brand
he owns it all through
so it's tough yeah and stuff it's also
it's also to hear him say you know being
like these guys screwed me and uh if you
saw his interview with our boy Lex
Friedman and Lex did a great thing he
goes you know it's it's a [ __ ] move not
to he goes you say all Jews but give us
specific examples okay there's a few
he's like well give us names you can't
just say because the in his business
we've all been [ __ ] over in business
you know I mean I've been [ __ ] over in
business
but it's not a Jewish thing it's those
individual things now the people he's
dealing with in music and merchandise
maybe they happen to be Jewish but the
majority of them aren't Jewish those
just happened you had some bad
interactions with those Jewish people
you know what I'm saying so like stream
was like well give us names you can't
just lump all of them together like give
us that like it's a [ __ ] not say their
names that's that's the cop out say
names can't even do it they got a little
heated too and and you know my thing was
just I thought he said Defcon but he
said death yeah death damn yeah
well you really I mean listen it was
sloppy you wish you had somebody who's
there like hey we know you're trying to
get out of the contract this ain't go
any other direction yeah but the best
the best way to put it is this if you're
Jewish think about this so there are
14.8 million Jews in the world Kanye has
uh what 16 million followers on
Instagram alone right you know what I
mean it's like you have more followers
than they're actually Jews in the world
so when a guy like that says that you're
like what the [ __ ] yeah well the problem
is is the radicalized and the the rare
people that follow them they're gonna go
even harder in the paint frame like yo
this is our guy so you think but you're
at the end of the day you think what
else I think it was a business move wow
you're just very very Slappy wow and I
mean also you know Connie's Connie's not
the first person to carry this narrative
in the black community the the people
that are really successful you look at
Kyrie Irving he's preaching the same
stuff Kendrick Lamar has lyrics
preaching this ice cube has lyrics well
you can even uh Michael Jackson did
remember yeah
this is a theme with very successful
African-Americans with black people
there's those very high level guys
notice they're not really saying [ __ ]
about Connie notice how a lot of
basketball players haven't said anything
about Kyrie Irving yeah there's a
there's this there's Kyrie is Kyrie
Irving playing next year does this all
this stuff he's not a distraction too
good he's too good and there's unless
Brooklyn has more issues now they're
just they're like hey we're the drama
team [ __ ] bring it we're The Real
Housewives of the NBA we want we're here
for the drama they just hired the Boston
Celtics coach who got fired for cheating
on this girl oh they did fire him they
hired them now here's the thing
basketball is very black and white we
want to win we want to win coach is
amazing yeah anybody would hire that
coach yeah yeah so they just hired him
they went unless we know the Kyrie
Irving thing we have other breaking news
we'll get to the Kyrie Irving thing the
whole anti-semitic in the movie stuff
real quick you know that Boston Celtics
coach has just been you know ran through
the [ __ ] gutters for cheating on his
wife with an employee and other people
and yeah you know she was married to the
allegations yeah yeah which you don't
hear about her no of course no yeah yeah
he has power although yeah so that that
guy that guy who did all that nasty
stuff he's our new head coach that's
hilarious
good that's not it's not he shouldn't be
canceled because he stepped out he just
marriage is complicated it takes two to
tangle with a [ __ ] nose you don't know I
don't know you know it's like it but uh
it's got 31.4 million Twitter followers
yeah that's just not Twitter alone yeah
that would make you right nervous if you
were Instagram was at 18 million which
is up to your point there'll be still
more than he is still he still has more
followers than Jews in the world uh
twice as many on Twitter so when
somebody like that says that that's
weird this was dangerous yeah sloppy I
don't I don't recommend it in any facet
but if your goal is to get out of your
contract you did it it did you took a
massive massive hit my man
massive hit hey B let's take a little
break because this episode of the final
kit is brought to you by Better Health
Better Health it protects your bro
listen you spend a lot of time in your
body working out nutrition but what
about your your psychological State yeah
and listen I wish my life came with a
user manual it doesn't all right so I
need some professional online therapy
and Better Health Online mental health
the next thing dude it's right there all
right and unfortunately life doesn't
come with a user manual so when it's not
working for you it's normal to feel
stuck in a rut all right
therapists there are trained to help you
figure out the cause of challenging
emotions and to learn productive coping
skills nobody teaches you how to cope
with all the negative thoughts you have
there and so better help helps you with
that it connects it's connected over
three million people with licensed
therapists three million and it's
accessible anywhere it's 100 online and
I've taken therapy I've done better help
it's good to talk to a professional to
give you an outside perspective they're
not biased just helping you solve your
problems they're there to help man all
right as the world's largest therapy
service better help has matched three
million three million with professional
licensed vetted therapists available 100
online
brief questionnaire they'll match you
with a therapist if things aren't
clicking you can easily switch to a new
therapist there are no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless search for the right
therapist it couldn't be simpler or save
10 off your first month betterhelp.com
fighter no waiting rooms no traffic no
endless searching for the right
therapist learn more safe temp stuff
your first month at betterhelp.com
fighter that's better help help.com
fighter hey B will you do me a favor and
tell some of our listeners and viewers a
little thing about nootropics from our
friends at on it with Alpha Brain look
alphabet have you heard of it yes Alpha
Brain they've used double blind studies
to prove that Alpha Brain is actually a
nootropic that gets you into Flow State
improves your memory gets the people
going it's a world-renowned nootropic
supplement with over 1 million bottles
sold Alpha Brain promotes cognitive
functions memory mental speed Focus
helps you remember names zero
non-complex tasks and help to think more
clearly under stress most of us are
under stress I personally know Joe Rogan
takes it every time he does a podcast
the reason you guys probably talking
about it man he swears by it and Joe
Rogan don't mess around all right
contains acids plant compounds
caffeine uh tolerant right you're like I
don't know if if it causes Jitters if I
take caffeine it's calf caffeine free
off brains caffeine free and here's the
best part about it on it so sure you're
gonna love Alpha Brain it's guaranteed
or your money back skim two weeks tell
them why you don't like it they will
send you your money back no return
necessary you can save 10 off your order
by going to audit.com
f-a-t-k that gives you 10 off Alpha
Brain but also attempts off the entire
damn website training gear kettlebells
Warrior bars protein powder whatever you
want we got you covered audit.com
f-a-t-k the attempts off Alpha Brain or
if you want to pick up Alpha Brain from
your local Walmart do that but help our
friends out here at finding the kid go
to audit.com
f-a-t-k Temp South Alpha Brain now let's
get back to the program but again you
know I've lost all faith in media like
you know what I was talking about [ __ ]
about Epstein on here or talking [ __ ]
about uh Pelosi and her husband all that
stuff well I'm skeptical I've lost all
faith in public media what they did to
Kanye at that soccer game I know exactly
how it went down I didn't see and what
they post and what the dragon he's him
talking [ __ ] to Mom Kanye's on hinge
Kanye is going through an episode no no
Kanye was there to see his son who
hasn't seen in a long time and the one
person he loves more than anybody on
this planet security stops them from
seeing his son at a soccer game and he
starts freaking out dude I would too
starts freaking out I would too and if I
was on a plane but if I was there I
would have helped them out you know what
I'm saying I would have helped them out
see his son so he used to in the middle
of the game run out there hug his son
because he had to get going and leave
and someone's filming that and some
mom's talking [ __ ] to him because he's
encouraged his son to like be aggressive
with the ball and kick the ball
so some Mom feels some type of way
starts talking [ __ ] to Kanye he's like
shut the [ __ ] what are you talking about
think about the the animosity the the
the the the anger you would have if you
went to go see your son lose my mind and
Amanda Ah that's what I say Amanda hired
security and then went they went you
can't see him no excuse me that's my son
it's got there's going to be a fight oh
I told my girl there's not if this
happened to us I'm telling you now
there's not Security on this planet that
exists unless they have guns that could
stop me from seeing myself that's gonna
be a bad situation I I get I get worked
up thinking about it all right when I
get to Texas it was happening in real
time getting texts about the soccer game
I was like oh if I was there I would
have helped him
they say the most dangerous man in the
world is the man who can't provide for
his family
I mean in acting class we used to say
that like this guy was playing his
character he's like the teacher stopped
and he goes what's your purpose here you
know the guy didn't think he was what
about the fact that you can't feed your
family that's the most dangerous man in
the world and a man who can't do that
wouldn't doesn't feel significant and
you took that right away from him that's
the kind of guy that picks up a gun and
goes to war or fights a bank too much or
whatever I would argue though I would
argue with that I would say the most uh
dangerous person in the world is the
incel a person a young man who has all
this aggressive energy but doesn't have
an outlet history would disagree with
that because oh man 2000 I'd say from
2007 till now would disagree with you no
no well what I'm saying is terrorist
movements and things like that are born
of the fact that you have no
representation that you your children
have no future you know when when when
you start there's that same when you
start killing the people's children they
Revolt you know that's that when you
take a man's child away from him uh and
a woman's child uh you will radicalize a
population for sure I mean well that
that's how the Isis and Al Qaeda start
right we're bombing them and then their
dads are dying then they have anger
towards America we got rid of all the
Isis here's the problem the Isis [ __ ]
see here's here's what happens you never
get rid of it you know how you don't
hear about the Isis anymore let me tell
you what happened with Isis Trump uh
well Isis decided they were going to
start throwing gay people off roofs
crucifying people raping women on mosque
taking women as slaves trading women as
slaves all that stuff okay you want to
get medieval cool now what happened was
the United States went good they're
Public Enemy Number One let's take our
you let's take our our people that are
super good at killing and you're not
going to see it you're just gonna
[ __ ] evaporate in the smoke and and
our intelligence agencies along with the
ground branch of the CI all these Delta
Force
greenlit that well Donald Trump Donald
Trump to you yeah because Obama did he
was like no to well Obama killed a lot
of people with drones actually um he
killed more people with drones yeah as
far as getting rid of Isis in the house
yeah was the Trump thing yeah yeah and
now listen Trump says but that I can
ride well Isis got a a load of of what
what happens professional professionals
you guys wanna you wanna throw gay
people off a roof and you want to rape
and trade women as slaves okay you want
to go do that to these CDs and stuff at
least the hounds release the hounds and
all the hounds look like Tim Kennedy
yeah they're Spartans now you're going
to meet professional Spartans and you're
all gonna [ __ ] die which is what
happened they died you want to
decapitate people like going to Villages
cool you're all gonna die and now where
are they oh they went away they just
disappeared I mean you never get rid of
them entirely but you know they had to
go to North Africa kill their whole
[ __ ] command structure yep
yeah you gotta do something about those
crazies got to do something about this
crazies and sometimes if people are
going to get medieval you got to get
medieval back Brandon and we have some
friends who get medieval yeah and not
even medieval but then you got medieval
if you've got medieval mentality with
21st century technology
I I've had I've been privy to just some
of how these guys do it I think drones
are too it's it's I mean obviously it's
the easiest way to get things done with
such a compact just like boom they're
over like I like I want my boys so I
heard just a little couple tidbits of
how some of our elite elite guys find
the Isis command or just the really bad
high value targets the people we know
have killed a [ __ ] load of people or are
The Architects of all the slaughter and
I was like I was like I go you know I
said to him I go well how would you ever
hide he goes no you don't hide you just
die oh there's no the only option is
there's a multiple choice question yeah
and it's a die be die see die
of the above I was like how the [ __ ]
would you ever you don't makes you proud
to be American you don't even know where
you don't see you don't know anything no
no
I was watching and because of Americans
but uh I was watching uh on Worldstar
they had uh Russia was had drones and
their Ukrainian soldiers in this
battlefield they lost but and they knew
their drones flying around so they're
trying to stay as still as possible
otherwise the Drone picks up movement
and goes to you so you just see these
guys stand there and then one guy just
goes like this talk to his buddy
and they see the jungle because the
drones no and you see them just like
they see it but they're like Frozen and
then it's too late and you see ding ding
ding ding boom no way yeah it's like oh
man
it that's a video yeah yeah dark
which says you look at these drones when
they make the one guy who died instantly
and another guy was like crawling out
he's pretty [ __ ] up but it's like
whole these drones man it's like it's
literally like Terminator and those are
Russian drones Americans have
the drones that can see yeah it has like
sponsorships on the side Annie Jacobson
who is a she wrote to surprise surprise
surprise
kill vanish okay it's a book called
surprise kill vanish and it's a deep
Insider look at the the our
assassination teams and like our tip of
the spear [ __ ] no no the actual
team yeah it's called surprise kill
vanish and um she want to pull a
surprise to finalists uh it's a really
interesting book I'm actually reading it
now the paramilitary units so CIA has
what's called Ground branch and they're
older they've been through usually if
you retire Delta Force or Green Berets
or SEAL Team Six CI is like if you want
we got the groundbreaking you tired of
wearing a uniform at all you want to
grow your hair long and just kind of do
you blend in yeah well use those brains
yeah and so she she had a guy
she used his name's name as Brett she
said I I Brett said that he was a
cultural attache
for the U.S embassy or something and I
but I knew there was no such thing as a
cultural attitude in the embassy he was
talking about from my things and so then
uh his kids he was helping his kids her
kids play with the GI Joes arrange it
show them what how you'd actually do it
and stuff and he goes you know um uh
I'll show you he had all these like kind
of like tactical cases
turns out he was he had arms in there
and he said I'll show you how a real Gun
Works and she said he set up it's this
is in in the canyon this is in uh the
Hill section of Los Angeles right in
Hollywood
and he set up his rifle for the boys
with a scope
and he was showing the boys how it works
first of all she was like what the [ __ ]
is he doing with this crazy gun is like
a sniper rifle yeah and so she looked
and he let her look through the scope
and he played with the scope a little
bit and she said across the canyon
across the canyon she could see
the veins on a leaf Jesus Christ and she
immediately knew what Brett did in
Afghanistan yeah and then she said
what's in that case what are you doing
because I know Jesus okay put your dick
yourself
is that how you're is that the gift your
wife uh the honey of the the actual SEAL
Team Six here and they're gonna run a
train on you that's my gift no on me
that's what I'm saying y'all oh thank
you baby yeah and then yeah she that's
her gift to me yeah that's your gift and
then and then you get to suck off a
five-star general Brian
and then she goes what's that what's
that [ __ ] thing and she goes he goes
oh that's uh and he opens it up it was a
knife
she goes what's that for and he goes
sometimes your job requires quiet and so
she said then she checked with her
sources and they said yeah Brett's not
that Brett works for ground branch which
is this special division of the CIA and
then she's decided to start writing this
book I have a Graham Branch tattoo on my
neck Branch but a ground the ground and
then a brain just a brain just a branch
on my neck yeah he's sick but you notice
how you hear a lot about you hear a lot
about steel Team Six but you never hear
about Delta Force they keep their mouths
shut no a lot of Seal team members are
pissed about all this I know yeah there
it is is a part of CA special activity
they call them branches huh branches I
don't know yeah it's it's uh you don't
want to be on the receiving end of those
guys that's that's the dark side right
there oh can you imagine being nice I'm
like man we got the branches oh my God
oh my God I would be like I quit I give
up I just walk around waving a white
flag that's what I would do because you
know you just going to die
yeah the best of the best though yeah
the best the best that's came Velasquez
right in the middle right
his child got pushed huh yeah what
happened not see him like on the street
no I saw him uh in court yeah what was
the deal they pushed his uh they pushed
his uh trial oh
yeah it went for anything he's just
still in there that's nuts I think he's
gonna be in there for a long time Bubba
I don't think uh I don't feel optimistic
yeah well I do apparently he's like I
thought we have a really close the
situation there's some [ __ ] we're not
hearing about yet oh really being
released during the trial that's why
Cain's like just wait oh wait he said
that
people very close to them like okay in
San Jose we're like just wait okay he
should be okay like wow wow I know
okay
it is insane he I mean granted he went
on that Rampage but it is insane that
that Predator is just out chilling at
home and Kane's in there
yeah a few days hearing except for
another seventh oh that's close yeah
what was that November 7th would be
three-fifths so that's next Tuesday
Monday Monday so Kane's chilling [ __ ]
sakes all right Jim what do you got
since we're here
alrighty um the first one's obviously a
sad one the rapper takeoff from Migos he
was basically murdered so I know you
don't know hip-hop but uh huge the Migos
so it was an uncle I think two uh
nephews like he was the nephew and one
of the other uh band members uh offset
it's his uncle who's married to cardi B
so you know cardi B but so they're the
Migos is massive massive and they're
breaking up but apparently they're
playing like
um dice or something yeah and uh bowling
alley that was closed yeah bowling
alleys it was like two in the morning
but I apparently he was shot from uh
gunfire but he wasn't he was just he was
a stray bullet oh no he wasn't the
actual guy they're eating before [ __ ]
isn't a shame but apparently he went on
a dream chance before and kind of
alluded to his death was like people
won't appreciate me till I'm gone like I
don't want to see it no I wouldn't
definitely definitely what happened man
what the [ __ ] they say that that guy
quavo cuevo cuevo yeah he had an
argument with some guys they were trying
to get in
there was and he was they're like
talking for like 30 seconds in an
argument and then someone started firing
yeah and he would just happen to be hit
by it he shot in the head and torso from
what I heard I didn't see this thing
about that it might have been from his
own camp like one of their Associates
because it was shooting like like his
old Camp started shooting first offset
gets caught in the crossfire and then
the other guy starts shooting back so
you don't know like but the the witness
there was like no I saw him fall off the
first shot that was scary
that people just pull a gun and start
shooting after 30 seconds they're
terrible terrible
and I guess the rapper designer I'm not
familiar with him but I guess he went on
Instagram saying some saying something
like he's gonna quit or whatever he
doesn't even rapper anymore something
like that because of all this stuff
happens it's so traumatic and depressing
I do think yeah so I'm going to die now
but I do think it's uh disrespectful
posting picture of him shot and stuff
like that like TMZ reporting that's like
Jesus Christ let the man let his family
just
grieve the Unspeakable you know [ __ ]
um do you even want to hear this or no
yeah I do okay
poor guy [ __ ] you go through some
[ __ ] man why why don't we do this why do
we do it why are we [ __ ] doing it
I swear to God I said ain't nothing I'm
direct I'm done right yo you
know I'm blaming I don't blame him well
that's that's all you need to hear I
don't blame him this version of me is
done it's done it's done it's done it's
done it's done nothing think about
it's done
y'all wanted it is um
y'all wanted it it's over
y'all what is it's over it just destroys
a home it destroys that like like when
you live in around that and you can't
escape it it I think that that kind of
PTSD that's [ __ ] real man it just
ruins you but often it ruins Amigos they
can escape it you're talking about one
of the richest bands in the world you
can't escape it you still can't escape
it because it's it's it's your fan base
it's your culture at that point let me
hang up two in the morning there's
things you can do it's just so what I'm
saying is that that ripple effect can
[ __ ] you're always having to fight
that you're always having to fight the
fact that I might die at any minute
you know I don't know God damn man sucks
man it's terrible yeah so sad the other
guy he got robbed in daylight the
the last rapper that we talked about
that got murdered there's jewelry oh in
L.A yeah yeah just in daylight with his
girlfriend yeah his girlfriend they
thought posted a picture and then they
found him and killed him they killed him
and before that pop smoke like a lot of
there's a lot left and right man man you
just shoot a guy for his [ __ ] jewelry
he just kills like he'll take his life
that that guy who died in L.A they
thought he had some issues in like
Philadelphia and they came here and
found them like there's been a running
thing it's awesome not sure what
happened yeah I don't know it's terrible
though terrible [ __ ] man
um let me see what this oh this is just
a quick one I just saw this and I guess
this tattoo artist was saying is his job
pretty much done with oh because now I'm
machines yeah it's like a laser
and it knocks it out fast I literally
don't know how to feel about this one am
I out of a job or is this awful yeah and
it's good work too and it takes seconds
yeah I would much rather deal with that
than sit there for hours getting [ __ ]
Inked blasted you know it's a matter of
time it's all this artificial
intelligence people are going to be out
of a job my friend who works with AI and
computer science he's telling me even
like I was like how could they replace
you know the people in the podcast
producers and he's like ever even the
hosts are replaceable through AI because
they learn what you're doing and you can
have like well people aren't gonna want
that no but I'm saying like but the
reality is if you're still gonna have
some comments but even if there's an
algorithm like it let's get all
defensive but uh but even if there's
like an algorithm yeah there's no way
could pick up what you're doing like
your personal story stuff like that the
jokes there's no way but it builds off
of what you've already done in the past
yeah you do in the future like for sure
it's kind of crazy with like articles
that come out they'll know how you
it's true that that the internet's a
sketch and every time I see a sketch now
I go internet's funnier
because I don't buy it might be funny
but the scenario is it's just somehow it
killed sketch because I can go on Tick
Tock or whatever and get the same kind
of
surprising experience you know or
whatever a short amount of time yeah I
remember I talked to uh Will Sasso about
that I said let's try to do a sketch
thing
3D and stuff and you know I was trying
to get him to join us and stuff and he
said the problem is that the internet's
A Sketch
I said what do you mean he goes well
it's you're competing with [ __ ] that's
already real life and hilarious and
that's one of the reasons Saturday Night
Live has lost so much of its relevance
you know I don't even know one person
but yeah yeah but if you guys did
sketches all the time I'd get it but if
you guys just throw one out once in a
long while I think it's really good yeah
I'd work yeah
maybe especially with our fan base yeah
if you're tailing towards the youngsters
on Tick Tock and stuff which again I
don't I've never even seen Tick Tock I'm
on there but I've never [ __ ] seen it
on pay attention to any of that I
disagree saying it's dead you could do
it especially you did it well yeah those
people aren't putting tons of production
they're not Comics you know if you did
it well that's mine yeah that's an Ellis
but the problem with SNL is it's so
corporate and so woke they have an
agenda right they [ __ ] themselves by
just lashing on leeching onto the Trump
stuff it was all Trump trump have you
seen the latest polls have you seen even
Caruso has tied with uh no hold up have
you seen New York
yeah yeah I do which there's a red wave
coming that I think is that's like
bigger than than it was uh when Obama
controlled both houses it's gonna be
[ __ ] nuts
be interesting people want safety they
want to hear about the economy economy
and safety yeah number one if you [ __ ]
with crime everything else you want to
talk about this and that's what happened
in the 80s yep that's exactly what
happened these people people go listen I
don't feel safe in New York so I I want
you know and it changes really fast a
million people in in New York up I think
up until between 1970 and 1980 left New
York City because of the crime one
million think about it one million my
friends my Dad's friend came in he had
an apartment on Central Park West and
said will you buy my apartment for one
dollar I don't want to pay these taxes
anymore yeah now of course it's 10
million dollars I looked more into that
Pelosi thing we're getting a little more
fact still didn't add up still a little
dicey no it's I told you
yeah but they both have hammers
and they're both in the underwear and
then they got he goes to the you know he
went to the bathroom were they both in
their underwear I don't know where that
I didn't see that I looked for that and
Chin yes find me one
just buy me one thing Rosie's husband in
his underwear Google that
but then also the guys kidnap them and
then it allows them take a phone into
the bathroom make a call that's not none
of that alarm
let's examine the false claims he
pop Pelosi let me just read a whole lot
one of the most viral false claims about
the attack says Mr Brooks a 82 and his
attacker David to Pat hold up
but maybe later oh there you go we're in
a same-sex relationship had a drunk or
quarrel a series of basic assumptions
that do not match official accounts of
the incident have been used to support
the narrative these claims started to
Trend in the U.S after Elon Musk created
an article from a website featuring
similar claims to his 112 million
followers on Sunday before deleting
history there's a tiny possibility blah
blah we know that okay but um can you
keep going is there anything else the
website Mr musklink has a history of
publishing inaccurate stories including
an article that's where Elon met [ __ ]
up okay one of the claims made on last
boat that Mr Department Pelosi were in
just their underwears police arrived at
the scene but the FBI complained against
Mr depab quotes a witness as saying he
was dressed all in black carrying a
large black bag on his back another
claimed hold on hold on B yeah in the
morning
listen I'm just going by what the
[ __ ] police said well no no you're
going by the FBI said
now did you hear on the cameras that you
had this guy get in and they have 24 7
security look at Mercury Taylor green uh
they're blaming Elon Musk for
misinterpret internet image information
about Paul Pelosi's friend attacking him
with a hammer
oh God
that according to the FBI complaint Paul
Pelosi did not know Mr depak Mr Pelosi
used coded languages he made a 9-1-1 cop
in the bathroom and an experienced
operator worked out what was happening
hey trump it wasn't a breakdown come on
who said that trump it wasn't a break-in
it was a breakout oh my God another
rumor supporting the idea that two men
knew each other claimed the shattered
glass of the door was broken from the
inside suggesting was supposedly or a
third person and let let Mr depap in
uh
I mean
yeah I it doesn't I don't see any Bubba
I don't see any evidence
on either side though you don't have any
questions but you're just like yeah it
all went like that no yes because he
sounds like he was a crazy man he's got
a history of being crazy if you look at
all the things he posted that were well
vetted from both sides he was a [ __ ]
nut first he was a left-wing guy the far
right guy then he's like talking about
everything else
uh you know um
yeah this guy is uh
this guy's a cuckoo bird I think he's
cuckoo bird
like gay cuckoo bird hey hey I don't
think he's all there they weren't both
in their underwear you're just spreading
this information and they both didn't
have hammers
I'm only going with what [ __ ] stories
I don't want the main stream I'm looking
at the FBI report but then also so you
want would you go off that with the
Russia collusion Trump
you read all that fine so you can bring
up Russian collusion on BBC or CNN but
it turns out that according to the FBI
we know that that was no no we don't no
we don't be after after a congressional
investigation but what I'm saying is
that in this case you're just saying
stuff I'm not though I'm not all I'm
saying a lot of questions
we're not allowed to have questions
until there's any evidence you have no
evidence
the police report is very
straightforward and not safe
notes tell me what you want to hear it's
BBC
it's insane to listen to these things Ah
that's the confusion I don't trust that
[ __ ] you do there's no way well I I just
I sound like any problem right now but
he's kind of [ __ ] right man these are
the same people that hit all the Biden
Hunter Biden stuff oh man how about 100
biting they just all the Russian
collusion it turns out 100
Pelosi to be gay so badly oh it's that
that's that's a fact those I mean he's
not I mean come on dude come on bro I'm
getting sucked off no dude easy easy and
and then they have 24 7 security
oh we didn't see it sorry we missed that
camera
oh
why are you turning into is it was he a
power bottom or a power top what do you
think
good question that's information I'd
like
I'm sure the video would show us that
the cop can would show us that I don't
think so and then he hits him in the
head while the cops are there oh no this
all tracked that's fine and then he goes
to the bathroom and uh makes a call well
the guy's clearly crazy he's in his
house
man there's no doubt that guy's crazy
it's very possible that crazy isn't
broken anything for it it's very
possible crazy man broken in Nancy
Pelosi's house because he considers her
the enemy that's possible a lot of crazy
people in the world dude who do you tell
that would be the most plausible yes or
no
the most plausible is that a crazy
person broke into went through all his
security hit him in the head in front of
the cops allowed him to make a call you
have no questions at all now I'm not
saying he's not crazy didn't break in
that happened but you're also saying
that there's some sucking and [ __ ]
yeah somebody was busting nuts that
night
it's just it's all a little too strange
for me if it's that easy to break into a
government every time Sam Tripoli every
time you disagree with them politically
you turn into a power bottom every time
I disagree with him he's like well you
need poppers for your nose cause your
[ __ ] I'm like you have to turn me am
I always getting [ __ ] no again I'm not
I'm not all in on this Theory just like
I was on the UFC right Wingers turn
every leftist into a power bottom and
that's the bottom line
yeah sir
I'm just it's just insane to me whether
you're left or right to buy into the
media's narrative after we've learned
from covid lockdowns all the [ __ ] that
they put out well that might be true but
there's no but I don't know
there's zero evidence and you're dying
for there to be ah no I'm not I just
want more evidence like give me the
footage why haven't we release the
footage
through all these right Wingers wrong
and release the footage why haven't you
done that because there's that when you
have an investigation and it's not no
they have to release them you don't no
no you don't you're not allowed to
release it to the public until you you
know you know I don't know goes to trial
okay well he's going to trial okay when
he goes to try all that stuff from his
lawyer will come out all I'm saying I
got quite it's a little too weird for me
you're not allowed to stay high before
the midterms and they're losing their
ass
just smell it
well they're gonna lose anyway
well the other going getting pretty
desperate yeah getting pretty desperate
yeah I don't think that's related sir no
no I get you don't have any questions
just like oh that makes all sense no I
don't have questions that high level
security in this insane not that high
level of security it is though so she
Twenty Thousand Seven thousands of
sitting congressmen and Senators
actually don't have you're wrong I'll
just prove that right now deceiving came
out and goes actually increase the
security while I'm out of town yeah but
that would be private security nope and
they have 24 24 7 government security
Pelosi housebreaking caught on security
camera sources say okay let's see that
let's see that watch this
all right in a packed San Francisco
courtroom
wearing an orange jumpsuit with a black
sling on his right arm was described as
a motionless as the judge denied bail
district attorney Brooke Jenkins he
plays blue balls how about you defend
the police thousands of potentials
that's what happens oh but that when you
demoralize the police you're going to
have that but you know by the way
it does look like there's a lot of
camera there's a lot of camera evidence
and the cops are looking at that I
promise and he's in big trouble he's
going to go to jail so it seems to me
that's a lot of this was on camera and I
need you to take back all your
conspiracy oh no listen of course the
thing this place is covered in cameras
right so when you take two broken no
alarm went off no no none of this is
weird to you well none of it at all well
hold on real quick and this is part of
our problem on the show Jim brought up
CBS News
sir
CBS News sir but I'm just saying all
this checks out to you sir there were
cameras no I'm just saying everywhere
Bubba and he still broke in okay and no
alarm went off well yeah but an elective
official's husband that's not what
strains you in any facet well and they
may be that the cameras weren't you know
maybe no alarm he's in custody he got
caught the cops get it got in there what
do you get caught his nasty wasn't
husband's gay let me see this all right
this is it let me see it just went away
there you go
I don't know what's happening
well they don't want that out do this
it's very interesting
oh that goes it's gone again wow it's
interesting it goes away
the CBS just is loaded fine right
hey
I'm just saying I don't know I'm saying
B I'm not no triple you oh I'm saying
this guy hold on no don't say questions
no don't say that man
uh and that's supposed to be his husband
well there's some weird ones no these
are tripling news yeah I went to Duck
Duck Go on okay but now I'm 100 a fan he
crashed the server of small alternate
news site that loves alternate new [ __ ]
just by retweeting a hilarious story
about Paul Pelosi is a gay dude who
picked up a gay prostitute who beat him
a little too hard he was paying for the
beating
uh I mean it's a great story which is
why I was so into it but then I see it
is see after all at 2 am how does the
gay prostitute just stroll into the
well-secured Mansion of a major
political figure he doesn't he was
invited in it's something it's 2 A.M and
he's dressed in all black suit with a
black backpack well that makes sense
because that's what you would wear at
2AM and no alarm oh I wouldn't set the
alarm I'm in San Francisco it's so safe
there right you have no question Brennan
there's it's all on camera the police
have looked at all the footage show me
the footage well if there's an ongoing I
know but show me the footage
oh oh I'm not allowed to see it okay you
will see it oh okay that works for me oh
then I believe them Brandon the San
Francisco Police Department are not
going to cover for Paul Pelosi they
would never they would never foreign
get recalled because crime's so bad at
all listen
it's been a rumor for years since San
Francisco Paul Pelosi is gay I don't
believe that
um
I mean
I love the story but unfortunately I
just need a shred if you give me a shred
of evidence but you can't you're just
you're just saying words into the air
I'm not and you're dressed like a gay
prostitute but that's not and listen if
I show up at 2AM you don't pay me my
money I'm cracking that
2AM I'm cracking the head
and you let me into your home I have to
go buy all the security and field some
type of way yep and you don't pay my
money yeah cracking that no cutting him
head you can you can squeeze me I'm not
gonna get these rocks off and you give
me a hammer Daddy yeah cutting that
really that's what happened
you crack me in the head yeah you got to
do yeah well you can just pay the bike
you could just squeeze a man until he
gave up sure the way he did react to
Michael Rapaport Rapport did uh you
popped his rib yeah he did break around
don't squeeze me
uh one more for me and I'll jump into
marks so this I saw on New York Post and
it was reported by the sun there's like
a Russian intelligence service that
found out through leaked emails emails
yeah demos that um Putin has the
beginnings of Parkinson's and he has
cancer I've heard this forever about it
but it's like through leaked emails it's
more credible I don't know so the
worrisome thing about this I heard
people talking about it if he wants to
do something crazy because he's not
gonna be he's gonna die yeah yeah I
agree that's what's scary oh geez
it's starting to sort of pancreatic
cancer what and he's on a bunch of
steroids apparently diagnosed with that
you go quick with that man
yeah so that's kind of scary that's not
good
um I didn't know Christina Applegate had
a mess yeah who gives up oh [ __ ] hey
hold on go down go down it says Putin
not expect to survive Ukraine conflict
intelligent Chief claims damn if the
conflict is another two years three
years whoa
well the guy right there the guy who
runs these Security Services is way more
hawkish than Putin is
damn another picture of him just looking
sad whoa like oh
he said he's got cancer
likely oh there's a picture too that
they saw that he might have IV through
his hands so it's like one oh the
bruising yeah
yikes
yeah one can hope right well I don't
know it's like a
oh no you don't pro and con well yeah
Khan would be he said I'm Gonna Leave It
Anyway release the Hound exactly nuclear
attack but hopefully the people around
him like absolutely not because yeah the
consequences
like as we use the hounds we drop these
nukes they're coming for us I think
it'll be a very good excuse for them to
be able to pull their troops out of
Ukraine a face-saving way of saying
Putin's now dead we're gonna pull the
Mastermind behind all this like we just
don't have the resource to continue this
that'll be a really good opportunity for
them
all right um you want to do the social
media ones yeah yeah
Mark Harleys
check this out
oh
yeah
visibility shield invisible shield you
made oh and you just sit in it
it hides you about 90 percent
not bad so you can kind of see like a
little bit of discoloration in there but
it somehow matches the colors behind him
and and almost I feel like that'd be
good for hunters right yeah yeah well
you know what's really good for hunters
and I used it is thermal a thermal scope
where you just have a binocular and it
just reads so you can look into a forest
yeah and you can see anything that's not
here no that's not hot it's unbelievable
that's stupid so the deer is hiding
foreign
so what you do is scan to see if they're
any deer then you use your scope and
zero in on it such a [ __ ] move come on
man I think the Native Americans are
using that [ __ ] look I'm just saying
bro and then you got your [ __ ]
heat-seeking missile to destroy the deer
yeah well it's just it just attracts it
yeah what's this
so this is from the 1971 Pro Bowl this
guy's got a jet yeah this is sick
well we do later have you seen what we
have now we have the water jet pads yeah
you know they got rid of pro ball
there's no more pro ball what since when
it's like a it's like uh do you hear
that they were they were telling Kerry
Lake if she wins if she wins the gov the
Republican governorship in Arizona the
NFL the NFL is not going to have they're
gonna boycott the [ __ ] Super Bowl did
you hear her talk about this so they
said so the NFL is talking about if you
win the Republican governorship they are
not going to have the Super Bowl there
and she goes so a bunch of billionaire a
bunch of billionaire owners aren't going
to have the Super Bowl because the
Republican has been elected governor by
the people of Arizona is that right and
how do they feel about all the fentanyl
coming over that was made by the
communist Chinese Communist party and
that's killing young people how do they
feel about that she's such a Savage holy
[ __ ] is she up on the oh yeah she's
gonna win she if you've seen what she
does she goes like this CNN goes we'd
love an interview with you she goes I
would love to do as long as it's on CNN
plus
he's here she goes oh that's right it
got canceled and it's because you people
are despicable but when you guys get it
back let me know thank you very much do
you see her do that no I'm Fair she's a
killer I'm gonna bring up Carrie Lake
it's [ __ ] oh my god dude it's like I
was like oh my gosh
oh that's right oh she's so funny about
that I was like are you [ __ ] kidding
me Savage me an end reporter yeah
um I'll do an interview okay as long as
it airs on sale or less does that still
exist I didn't think so because the
people don't like what you guys are
peddling
thank you
they didn't she didn't let go holy [ __ ]
Savage
because the people don't like what
you're paneling have a good day holding
on to her what happened here you don't
have a mask oh because when I see oh
I'll do on CNN plus that's still exactly
it's hard to argue oh it doesn't have a
good day
that looks like such a bad idea oh she's
such a badass she's just that guy look
if you're gonna be a p if you're gonna
if you're if you're the press and you're
gonna be unfair on a piece of [ __ ] to
people they're gonna be a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] to you about it and I think that
you just got to be you got to be honest
I'm a fan hilarious
let's go I got a couple
before you can emulate a storm
experience in a storm room that's kind
of cool
it's like The Truman Show
I wonder if there is sharks in here
pretending I'm having a good time
pretending on like
thinking a shark is going to get JK I am
just like is this unpleasant or is this
supposed to be fun that looks pretty
cool though do you make like a tsunami
in a storm room you get to get in a room
and it's just a storm well we're kind of
a waste of time right as far as like
money and revenue
yeah that's one time like you want to go
sit in the storm again no I did you were
in a mile a coal mine it'd be cool if
you had like a room you could go in
there that had sunshine and palm trees
coal mine yeah because you know how the
coal miners have to work in like in
North Korea they they stay and they get
no vitamin D they're gonna die it's a
great time you don't want to work in a
North Korean coal mine that that's
really not that's hell on Earth yeah all
right all right
yeah so I guess the White House sent out
a tweet that was taking credit for a
boost in retire with Social Security
checks on Wednesday but then they're
like wait a second that's just uh that's
just a function of uh um what's it
called oh yeah inflation right so you're
you're it goes up anyway with that yeah
oh god that's literally where the
Democrats are though they're so
desperate that they're re did you did
you see by saying he met the guy you
created insulin yeah that was that was
that's been used since the 1930s it's
been easy since the 19th he wasn't born
then okay he also said that his son
Hunter who died of brain cancer in 2016.
I'm sorry uh uh Beau went very
tragically but said my my son died in
Iraq no he didn't no he didn't you know
he'd made a whole bunch of old grandpa
that you know no he also lies though I
mean I don't know if you remember when
he was younger I graduated with three
degrees top of my class none of that was
true again I was just too old too when
he was young yeah yeah now he's older
you know yeah plagiarism yeah I get it
he made some mistakes I don't like
making fun of him for being old actually
and I don't like making fun of him for
having you know maybe some cognitive
issues I don't and he also had a stutter
he has a stutter people don't realize
yeah you can't be the leaders yeah free
world though you can't vote that in yeah
make fun of the people who voted for him
knowing all this yes it's not his fault
whoa what's this
yes I guess this guy was uh defrauding
people in the Muslim Community but you
know also it's one of these things where
you know if somebody's reaching out to
you about whatever Bitcoin investment or
something like that what was this hustle
well I guess he would solicit money from
Muslim New Yorkers
um in return for stock and then you
would send them uh you know doctored
images of the stock or the
cryptocurrencies
um
and it's it's very common you see this
online where people will send you these
like images of like look how much money
I got this guy just deposited this thing
and I guess you know I guess
you're shitty yeah shitty yeah
bad dude we pocketed eight million
dollars in the scam and blew it all on
personal expenses and gambling
smart I don't know man some people are
shitty
yeah this one yeah
yeah tick tock on faces criminal charges
after hitting golf ball into the Grand
Canyon turns out because people are like
doing tours below
yes I think it was probably like yeah
I mean all right she's got seven million
followers on the social media platform
um
ah
I'm sure it went viral but yeah you have
to assume I don't know what you're doing
oh there it goes that it's very illegal
you know to throw anything in the Grand
Canyon
um just because it's a who's coming out
the uh the National Park Service I guess
yeah let's be fine she'll get a fine yes
you have to pay some money yeah it's
just I just saw this from Mark that I
think I want to look at he said stop
calling them influencers they're just
dumb asses
this one's insane dude yeah oh hard
passes
family terms beloved expired golden
retrieve into a rug that girl who killed
that husky should do this that's really
wild to do it looks comfortable though
it does look comfortable
it's creepy but you remember your dog oh
and his nose you get to cuddle with him
and stuff like let's not have a nose
though huh yeah face I don't know I feel
I'm kind of like yeah I'm torn I'm torn
in my feelings I just frowned upon is it
yeah I don't like it man though that's
comfy comfy otherwise it just goes to
waste yeah if you if you just told me
about it I think it would have been
really turned off but now seeing it it's
like I could land that you know yeah
there's something creepy about it yeah
yeah it's creepy but it's calm yeah I am
torn as well what if you did the same
thing with a Frills cat fine with that
Lush like like a hairless girl yeah it's
just the bed yeah it's on your floor
yeah but I will say that uh that's kind
of cool
oh I know that's weird too it's weird
but to have that fur is that it feels
that's pretty much it keeps you warm
that's it well guys oh wait wait go
ahead run look go ahead go ahead I was
gonna I thought you're gonna do the
merch thing first but I'll just wait
till you say it wish I was in San
Antonio Texas because I just said well
I'm going to be there I'm going to be in
San Antonio I don't know what to do
there's nothing I'll be there in San
Antonio I'm in Santo this week Thursday
Friday Saturday Friday and Saturday
almost sold out tickets left for
Thursday's show tiger thick will be
available this Thursday Friday Saturday
baby well my favorites the LOL come get
some San Antonio Texas and I just can't
get enough of Texas because next week
I'm in Houston Houston Improv Thursday
Friday Saturday at the specs I'll post
the address on uh tiger thick I'm doing
a tiger thick meet and greet try you can
try the award-winning whiskey we have it
all there San Antonio will have the
tiger thick Houston will have the tiger
thick bottles will be available to
everyone and tastings and all that stuff
so I'm at the specs it's on Saturday at
noon from uh 12 to 2 I'll post the
location of the specs in Downtown
Houston
but I'm at the Houston Improv Thursday
Friday Saturday next week San Antonio
you're up this week and then merch the
new uh thick diet merch drops this
Friday at 9 00 a.m Pacific on
thickboy.com so get you some merch right
now you've seen all the boys wear it the
long sleeves the hoodies the t's
available at thick boy.com at 9am this
Friday and I end uh the month in
Milwaukee Milwaukee improv November 18th
through the 19th and then I close out
the year in Providence Rhode Island and
Washington DC uh DC Improv get you some
um Charlotte North Carolina Comedy Zone
November 10 11 12. Addison Texas Addison
Improv the next weekend November 17 18
19. Naples Florida off the comedy club
December 1 through 4. I got niacc
December 8th through 10. still not on my
website still not up let me write it
professional see you there kids
all right kids this the fine kid we're
out it's the it's there now we gotta
know West Nyack New York B it's on there
hey I just had to refresh yeah it's on
there oh there you go there you go Nyack
New York Liberty Live all right kids
this is the fine kid we're out